all right so i'm late to learning about
this
apparently exceptionally late there's a
theme park universal studios japan and
they've built a nintendo world
it's about damn time how i had no idea
about this
until this day shocks me i thought this
was just a dream that they were thinking
of doing in hollywood i didn't know they
were like launching its actual japanese
park
so there's this 45 second trailer on ign
let's see what this is all about
wait is that that's that's real
i think it's digital i think the first
shot was
digital
whoa oh
no whoa
[Applause]
yeah oh my goodness oh
oh i got nipple chills oh man
[Music]
we are mario holy moly
that i it's just so bright and technical
what the hell yeah just looks like the
games came to life why is there no
information
hold on that's a mario kart ride that's
a
mario kart ride dude there's a mario
kart
ride there's no other way around it is
it going to be interactive i mean
they've got to be on the cutting edge of
theme park technology
oh my god okay wow
um a little mind blown
japan so lucky yeah yeah they are
i mean especially too because from at
least what i've heard from friends who
live there they actually have a lot of
the classic rides that our
park has retired to like back to the
future and stuff so
you can go relive your 80s gaming and
movie love all at the same time
i'm very much shocked by what we just
witnessed right there i saw something
about super nintendo world and then i
saw this trailer pop
up on ign on our notifications and i was
like what
this is real fun apparently
look at this quick research has been
announced for years and i have no idea
about it
in two months two months from now oh man
talk about wish fulfillment come to life
a chance to really mean we're never
getting those nintendo live action
movies but this could be the closest
thing getting to it this should
certainly outdo lego land oh my god oh
yeah maybe you can get eaten by one of
those giant
you know pipe dwelling i forget what the
names are but you know the venus fly
traps
i'm trying to say stuff but to be honest
i'm just more shocked that it exists
they gotta have like a a floating box
with some kind of like
flexible material so you can jump into
it and like win prizes or something like
think of the possibilities
oh boy all right guys well super
nintendo world
are you going you all going leave your
thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
give some information and down below oh
i'm so baffled
i'm so baffled by that pleasantly
surprised
oh my god all right bye